when Wagner Fighters occupied the
Russian town of rostov and then started
advancing on Moscow last month the
Wagner boss yevgeni pregosian seemed set
on a self-destructive path of direct
confrontation with the Kremlin
commentators and analysts assessed that
precaution had gone too far this time
that he'd left President Putin with no
choice but to chop him down
the Wagner Advance was grounded a mutiny
and on June 24th Putin's assessment of
it was uncompromising
what we are facing now is treason
unreasonable Ambitions and personal
interests lead to treachery State
treason and betrayal of our own people
just 200 kilometers shy of Moscow
progression called off the advance the
belarussian leader said he'd mediated a
deal and progression and his mercenaries
were being sent to Belarus
the whereabouts of precaution and
assessments of his likely life
expectancy were the topics of intense
speculation now Moscow has revealed that
just five days later President Putin
invited him to meet face to face in the
Kremlin
foreign it is true that the president
did have this meeting he invited 35
people to it all the commanders of the
units and the management of the Wagner
company including pregosian himself that
meeting took place in the Kremlin on
June 29th it lasted for almost three
hours
according to peskov the Russian
president was in listening mode
the commanders provided their account of
what happened they stressed the fact
that they are loyal supporters and
soldiers of the head of state and the
commander-in-chief they said that they
were ready to carry on fighting for
their motherland
where this leaves the power struggle
between pregosian and the Russian
defense Ministry is unclear on Monday
General garasimov the Russian military
Chief of Staff appeared in public for
the first time since the Mutiny more
than two weeks ago Russian defense
minister Sergey shoigu has made several
public appearances and seems to still
have the trust of Putin the camp in
Belarus which was prepared to receive
exiled Wagner Fighters remains empty and
reports that pregosian had been banished
by Putin now seeing far less convincing
as the saying goes keep your friends
close and your enemies closer Paul
Brennan Al Jazeera